MUCH.
AP
G US, I WANTO BRING YOU
TA INDICTED FORMERE CHARGES,
STEMMING FS TOOVERTURN JOE BIDER
ELECTIONA.
ATON INDICTED.
LET ME BRINGCOLLINS
RIGHT NOW, NOT
RE INDICTMENUNSEALED.
>> YES.
S KAITLAERE.
INDICTMENT?I
P?
?
>> IT' INDIVIDUALS.
IS8-PAGE
INDICTMENT, IT'S GONNA TAKE USMI
BUT, JAKE ONE HE MIMPORTANT PAR,
BURE OTHIS.
ANALTRUMP, RUDY HN
MAMEADOWS,ON
CANNEDTHIS
ANOTHER UNINDICTED
IN THE PREVIOUS
INDICTMENT.
Y DID. A THA
JENN ATTORNEY,
HIY, MIKISCI
NDLING FHAT TIME PERIOD.
FROM THE
O  OF THWIINVESTIGATORS IN JACK.
HIS NAME IS ON HERE.
CAMPAIGNING ROLE THAT IS ALSON A
PART OWITH SOMEBODY WHO IS PART
I AM READING OFF THE SHEETHE
W THAT WE SEE SEVERAL
DIFFERENT CHARGES FOR WITNESSES,
WHONSEO
GNOF COURSE, MARK DI
MEADOWS BEING ON THERE.
F OF THE THINGS THAT
TH IS THAT
ERNOL INDITRD SIX UNNAMED
THID, TT',S, FOUR OF
N,K.
IDENT
TRUMP'S
CHIEOFE
HOUS RINGLEADER OF
E CONSPIRACY.
SUSPEEDE
S NOT A COCOR
EDT, WAS C
IS INDICTED
IN THIE DI>> YES, TRGIA PARTICU,
HE WAS THE O
G CALLS TO
GI OFFICIALS.
HE WAS THE TN
TO GRGNT SIHE WAS THE ONE WHO WE
RAEN THAT RM, BEFORE
JANUARY 6TH.
OOM
WITH TRUMP, G
CALLING HIM IN.
AT GEORGIA
OFFICIALS,YOU TALKO HIM
RANGIN CALLS, A
PART OF THIS.
SOE TIIN ASPECT TO OTHERS WHEN I
THE LAST TWO D
SO IT IS RY O
SEE NAME IN HERE.
TO SEETHPAIGN
S, PEOPLLIROMAN WHO IS NOT A
NAME, HE I
DAY-TO-DAY PARTS ILING OUT ABTT
D I THINK YOU W THE FIRST
PAGE OTHOTR
OR EIGHT OTHER
19 TOTAL I BELIEVE,
INCLUDING DONALD TRUMP.
SO JUST THE
THE --
>> WHAT YOU GAVE US WAS NOT THE
BUT ITLLGONNA 'S ANOTH
UGH TH.
ESIDENP OBVIOU RUDY, JOHN EASTMH
CAMPAIGN LR, THE WISCOINL S, THI
POLITICAL OPATCHEESEBOROUGH.
ENNA CLARK, THE FORM
ELLIS, FORMER REPUBLICAN
NATIONAL COMMITTYER.
RACE MID, ROBERT JULIEMIN, AND D
SS
STILL,TEPHENLIFF GALRRILLIAM PR,
TREVEYON KUTI, OR KATI ISYL, S
IMFEHIND CLOSEOR CRAZY WITH HEC.
D SSY HAMPTON, A KCOTT H
>>'SCTUALLY A VERY
INTERESTING ONE,N A
RECOGNIZED.
UTPERVISOR, THE STORY THAT
FTWARESE TAC
D A ROLERGIA, SHE HA
IN THAT.
I BELIEVE  J
SE MCMAN
NUMBER A